my name is anything sua I'm a visual
artist from what excited Argentina my
artwork is a lot about accumulation
mainly collage and sculpture and I work
with all kinds of materials and disuse
the images are always symbols of power
of money of the consumer society and
it's also a lot a lot about a success
and a lot about how we wish to be
remembered in history what I like to see
when I finished one of my pieces is how
each object dialogues with the object
beside it some kind of toy beside a
calculator beside a pen it's surprising
to see different objects close to each
other that are not meant to be close to
each other
you can feel that I like to think how
this trash was resurrected I think
that's really like gives you hope things
can change and things can be better and
every object has a second chance to be
something else something new something
valuable